Андрій із позивним "Артист" робить свої перші кроки на протезі.
Він разом із батьком пішов воювати 24 лютого у десантно-штурмові війська.
А в серпні підірвався на міні під час контрнаступу на Херсонщині.
У мене дзвін у вухах, вибухи ще довго тривали.
І буквально через 5 секунд, коли я повернув головою ліворуч-праворуч,
почав кричати. Кричати від болю, бо вже не було правої ноги
і лівої теж майже не було.
Праву ногу ампутували, а ліва - дуже травмована, її оперували вже кілька разів.
Тепер Андрій на етапі протезування.
За день до того я дуже переживав.
Я не знав, як зроблю перший крок. Зробив перший крок. Звичайно, сподобалося.
Боляче, тяжко, багато поту виходить. Знаєте, зараз начебто стаю на тимчасову ногу,
не на свою, і таке відчуття, ніби мені на плечі 50-60 кілограмів кидають.
Дуже сильно хочу додому, повноцінно бути вдома, гуляти з дитиною.
Протезування в Україні є безкоштовним для усіх - як військових, так і цивільних громадян.
За офіційними даними, станом на червень понад пів тисячі українців
потребували протезування та реабілітації через втрату кінцівок.
Наразі Україні вже потрібно удвічі більше фахівців у галузі протезування,
визнають в уряді. Близько пів сотні наявних центрів перевантажені.
Про стрімке збільшення кількості запитів та черги на протезування
розповідають і в Центрі протезування, ортезування і реабілітації "Без обмежень".
Якщо брати 2014 рік - це були мінно-вибухові поранення, якісь прильоти,
плюс були режими тиші. То зараз ця активна фаза нон-топ
і, на жаль, люди отримують якісь травми.
У центрі з представництвами у дев'яти містах цивільним у межах державної програми
пропонують протези для ходьби та плавання, а військовим - ще й високофункціональні спортивні.
У нас 50% військових точно вертаються на фронт.
І не те, що там десь сидять писарями чи ким, а він воює по повній програмі:
від водолазів до глибинної розвідки. Дуже багато людей далі роблять своє діло.
Їхати за якісними протезами за кордон не обов'язково.
Фахівці вже навчилися збирати їх в Україні. Комплектуючі підбирають з найкращих у світі.
Якщо найкраща, ми знаємо, стопа в Америці, ми її купуємо в Америці.
Якщо найкраще коліно гідравлічне в Англії, ми його купуємо в Англії.
Якщо найкращий клапан, протяжка, модуль або будь-яка деталь в Німеччині,
ми його купуємо в Німеччині. Основні країни, яким ми віддаємо пріоритет -
це Англія, Німеччина, Бельгія, Швеція, Америка, Японія.
Тобто найкраще, що є у світовій протезній галузі, ми черпаємо звідти
і ставимо на наших хлопців і дівчат.
З наступного року у центрі планують виготовляти навіть біонічні руки,
де окремо рухається кожен палець і можна давати фізичні навантаження.
На нову ногу в центрі протезування чекає й морпіх Олексій із 503 окремого батальйону.
Чоловік втратив власну під час штурму на Донеччині.
Але після протезування хоче продовжувати службу.
Я скажу, що протез - це не так страшно. Я вважаю, що 21 століття - це століття технологій.
І якщо в тебе друга нога буде залізна, то це навпаки навіть крутіше, ніж дві звичайних.
Треба шукати позитив, і я такий знайшов позитив. Навіть не те, що знайшов позитив,
а я навпаки пишаюся, що в мене буде друга така нога. Що буду нестандартною людиною.
Щоб знову поставити людей на ноги, у майстерні трудиться Володимир Федоров.
Він працює техніком-протезистом вже 43 роки.
Ми приймаємо людину, проходить огляд. Як огляд пройшов, якщо йому можна,
ми робимо гіпсовий зліпок. Беремо цей гіпсовий зліпок, заливаємо гіпсом.
Виходить, був негатив - став позитив.
Оцей позитив я повинен увігнати у його розміри.
І я пам’ятаю дуже добре, де його всі болючі місця.
Кожен протез виготовляють індивідуально. Спочатку роблять гіпсовий зліпок,
потім модель кукси - кінцівки, яка залишилася після ампутації,
а далі - куксоприймач. Вже його кріплять до заліза.
Треба вкласти душу у протез. Якщо так не вкладаєш і робиш, як конвеєр
- воно нічого не буде. Треба трішки попихтіти, попотіти і тоді щось вийде.
Це не так просто.
90% всього - це модель. Як зняв модель, як її зробив.
От зробив модельку гарну, на людині сидить, ніде не тисне, ніде не натирає,
він комфортно себе почуває. І оце успіх. Я кажу: встань і йди.
Щоправда, ходити захисників доводиться буквально вчити заново.
Свої перші кроки вони роблять під наглядом фізичних терапевтів і техніків.
Починаємо ми з брусів. Одягаємо протез, спочатку вчимося тримати рівновагу, баланс.
Потім робимо перші кроки. Навчаємо їх робити однаковими, з якої ноги йти:
з протезу, зі здорової, як тримати спину.
Бо ці навички втрачаються за цей час, поки вони в лікарні.
Потім ходять із паличкою, стають на бігову доріжку і долають сходи.
А дехто - перелазить через паркани і мріє зробити сальто на батуті.
Як-от Роман. Із початком повномасштабного вторгнення чоловік пішов
в окремий полк спецпризначення "Азов" Київ.
Під час штурму ворожих позицій на сході потрапив під обстріл із танка.
Осколок від снаряда розірвав ногу.
Я досить недавно почав на ньому вже бігати. Перед цим я не міг ще, не були готові м’язи.
Я можу боксувати на ньому, тобто займатися боксом, вільно пересуватися,
перелазити вже якісь забори і тому подібне. Досить активно.
Я півтора місяця вже лажу на протезі і можу собі дозволити вже деякі речі,
не просто ходити. Як зроблять вже новий культеприймач,
я піду на батут стрибати сальто вже у протезі.